In this problem, a building exists on a plot next to which an 8-foot-deep excavation is being made.
The bottom of the excavation is planned to start 15 feet away from the building,
and will then slope upward until it reaches the ground surface.
According to the OSHA technical manual regarding excavations,
the soil in this area has been classified as Type C.
It is desired to leave some amount of horizontal perimeter strip next to the building.
What is the maximum permissible width of this perimeter strip in feet?
So, all this problem really requires is finding the slope of the slope requirements for Type C soil,
and then solving for some basic geometry.
So, we have our excavation depth here, the total distance away from the building in question here,
and we need to know how much distance might be available for a strip perimeter strip,
depending on the value of the slope or the steepness of the grid.
So, the first thing we can do is we can search either OSHA or Type C into our reference manual,
and that only is to section 3.10.3 slope configurations in layered soils.
The problem doesn't mention anything about multiple layers of soil,
so we can assume that there is only one layer.
So, as we can see in our table, our excavation for Type C soil is less than 20 feet deep,
and the slope requirements are 1.5 horizontal to one vertical.
So, we want to know how much room there is for a perimeter strip.
So, we need to know the horizontal length of the slope.
Solving this equation will give that to us.
So, we know that 1.5 over 1, which is going to be x over y, equals x, which we don't know yet over on this side,
and y is going to be 8 feet.
So, solving for this, x equals 12 feet.
So, finally, all we have to do, we can find the space available for a perimeter strip
by subtracting the horizontal length of the excavation from the total horizontal distance from the bottom of the excavation to the building.
So, we now know that there is going to be 12 feet of space required,
the horizontal length required for a slope of Type C soil,
meaning that if we have 15 feet and we need 12 feet,
then 3 feet of horizontal distance will be left over here for a perimeter strip.
And that's all it takes to solve this problem.
Simply knowing where to find your slope for Type C soil, and then how to apply it with some basic math.
And that's it.